معنا من تل ابيب مراسل الجزيره الياس كرام
الياس اذا اطلاق لصواريخ من شمال قطاع غزه
باتجاه مواقع اسرائيليه ايه رسائل تحملها
مثل هذه الدفعات من شمال غزه مع اتمام بعض
العمليات كما اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي في
الشمال هي رسائل حقيقه تحرج المستويين
السياسي والعسكري في اسرائيل الذان
يحاولان القول بانهما انجازا انجازا
عسكريا كبيرا في قطاع غزه من حيث القضاء
على قدرات المقاومه الفلسطينيه تحديدا
العسكريه منها وكلما حاول المستوى السياسي
او العسكري الترويج لما يسمونها انجازات
او صوره انتصار على المقاومه الفلسطينيه
ياتي رد المقاومه الفلسطينيه عاجلا وسريعا
سواء كان ذلك على شكل عمليات نوعيه تستهدف
القوات الاسرائيليه او على شكل اطلاق
صواريخ او دفعات من الصواريخ باتجاه منطقه
غلاف غزه واحيانا ايضا باتجاه العمق
الاسرائيلي لتؤكد المقاومه من جديد بانها
ليست فقط قادره على التصدي للقوات
الاسرائيليه المتوغلة
ريخ واستهداف البلدات الاسرائيليه الواقعه
في منطقه غلاف غزه واحيانا كما قلت في
العمق الاسرائيلي وان المقاومه الفلسطينيه
ما زالت قادره حقيقه على تحديد المكان
وعلى تحديد الزمان وعلى اختيار المديات
التي تستهدف فيها المواقع الاسرائيليه
وهذا ما من شانه ايضا ان يلقي بظلاله ايضا
على مخططات كانت لدى الحكومه الاسرائيليه
بعوده تدريجيه للاسرائيليين الى مناطق
سكناهم في البلدات الاسرائيليه في منطقه
غلاف غزه اسرائيل حاولت ان تفعل ذلك مع
مطلع العام الجديد وقبل ذلك ايضا باسابيع
قليله كان هنالك رفض كبير من جانب
الاسرائيليين في تلك المناطق بالعوده الى
بلداتهم الاسرائيليه لانهم كانوا ينظرون
الى واقع الحال الى الواقع العسكري في تلك
المناطق حيث كانت المعارك على اشدها ما
بين الجيش الاسرائيلي والمقاومه
الفلسطينيه وكانت المقاومه الفلسطينيه ما
زالت قادره على توجيه تهديد للقوات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه في منطقه غلاف غزه
وبالتالي ايضا توجيه الصواريخ باتجاه هذه
البلدات الاسرائيليه لذلك هم رفضوا العوده
الى منازلهم والى بلداتهم الاسرائيليه
وبالتالي اجبرت الحكومه الاسرائيليه على
تمديد فتره تمويل بقائهم في الفنادق ودور
الضيافه التي لجوا اليها بعد احداث السابع
من اكتوبر الماضي شكرا لك الياس كرام
مراسلنا من تل ابيب
نوه